[Applaudissements]
tu veux cet accroc ni la delormeau dance
les amis attention la petite ballerine
deux des huit ans ouvrait le black swan
de la région ya peu nous vous arrivez
dans la douleur modèle des nouveaux pas
il nous les expliquent qu'ils sachent
contactant alors ils créent des nouveaux
pas où est la ruhr lui revenir c'est qui
la fondent dans le gard il est même
plafond peut plus l'arrêter il
engueulait même les invités qui sont
venus avec nous faire les boys nouvelles
de leurs mots dance vous êtes payés oui
c'est parti c'est parti on y va regarder
[Musique]
salut à tous vous êtes chaud bienvenu
pour un nouveau numéro de la de leurs
modèles jacques b boys salut les gars
ont alors d'un fois c'était un petit peu
facile et vous avez niveau pour passer
un level supérieur mais pas de panique
on va le passer ensemble de leurs mots
dance allez c'est parti on démarre avec
le classique le retourner à gaza et 3,4
retourner à gacé regarde bien au loin
j'avance un petit peu oui je suis sexy
je suis canon à les déhanchés fripons up
à droite à gauche à droite en serait à
gauche à l'ehpad locaux un petit coup à
droite web hymne attention coeur sur toi
on vise bien l'amour ça peut blesser
et attention n'ouvre pas le cabri on
part à gauche yep yep
qu'est-ce qui fait le cabri quand il est
à l'aise à l'ailé mais les bras 360 de
l'amour ouais bien sûr les appuis et
juste derrière c'est le pas flash dance
allez on y va on essaie que sur les cra
des cigarettes en achour nation'' h au
hashtag je brûle d'impatience
ensuite on les sent très très bas et on
sort
oui ça ce n'est pas de leur modèle on
souffle un petit peu à quoi un grand
verre d'eau et puis au piano
[Musique]
allez on s'est bien reposé en musique je
suis sûr que vous êtes prêt pour cette
nouvelle version de la doller moderne
levé vous chez vous et on y va tous les
boys camille brahim jean-marc kamel mon
mot cartman brad boyes a les positions
départ bien entendu toi on y va 3 2 1 à
munich
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de la vendée
tél
[Musique]
m
bravo rabot chez bourdin cartonné pour
tous très vite pour une nouvelle version
de la tôle en modèle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
son fils
[Musique]